[Music]
[Music]
okay welcome to the lecture serious God
in computer which we are running this
fall today's the seventh lecture the
eighth lecture actually and to adjust
for the people who have not been here
before just to give them a brief summary
of what we did so far we started with
four lectures on what is it what does it
mean to be human
on what was called the human factor and
we heard an engineering perspective and
ethology perspective ethology
perspective a brain and cognitive
science perspective and an AI
perspective then we had a part which we
have today the last lecture of personal
reports kind of case studies on how
scientists deal from various backgrounds
deal with existential issues within and
outside of their research we had first a
Christian perspective than a Buddhist
perspective last week we had a Jewish
perspective and today we have a Hindu
perspective and the next the last two
lectures both after Thanksgiving will
deal with how to build it or is it
possible to build it next week we don't
have electricity we don't have a lecture
because of Thanksgiving and for all
people who are totally unhappy about
that we have next week a discussion
group Monday at 12 o'clock at Harvard
Divinity School which is 45 Francis
Avenue over at Cambridge and the the
discussion group is run by Professor
Harvey Cox and me so for everyone who
has questions about the lecture series
wants to discuss some stuff
12 o'clock Harvard Divinity School 45
Francis Avenue I'm happy to answer every
emails my email address is eight and an
EF like forest at AI dot mit.edu and
here also brochures I have a couple of
them outside and a couple of them inside
including my email address and all the
other information so you want in you
want to perhaps know and now I'm very
happy and very glad to
welcome professor Bijoy misra here today
professor misra is physicist originally
and godess PhD 1977 from Pew University
in India he came then to MIT as a
researcher and worked in the energy lab
and since 1982 he has been affiliated
with a Smithsonian Astrophysical
Observatory and the Harvey in Harvard
and he is now a faculty member for
computer science at the Harvard
Extension school and also consultant in
the Department of Radiology
and neurology at Harvard Medical School
so already in the science there is a
variety of different interests but for
for very interested for this serious is
beside all these scientific interests as
he has a very strong interest in Hindu
tradition and Hindu religion coming from
an Orthodox Hindu background he works a
lot he is very very active in research
on Hindu religion Hindu philosophy and
also Sanskrit and Hindu and Indian
culture in general right now he's
working on a high resolution mapping of
the brain and today he will talk about
the insights from his research with that
project with regard to his Hindu
tradition he will focus on Shankara
whose work he also has in part
translated and I think this is a just
wonderful background in both science and
religion and so I'm very very glad and
happy that you're here today and tell us
the ideas thanks for coming
[Applause]
thank you
when Ann called me um several months ago
for creating to creatively lecture for
this series I kind of initially thought
that I will I will talk about cognition
cognition cognition as a topic has
interested me strongly because more and
more as I grow older I believe that we
become prey to perception perception in
a sense of electrical engineering that
is where is the signal what is the
signal do we have a signal can we get
the signal how much of error is there in
our sights in our hearing in our feeling
in our overall sensory reception how did
I come to feel about this strongly is
different people scientists various
enlightened people various people with
lot of information will present
information somewhat differently that is
how I felt that we must have a good
understanding of perception however when
I wanted to prepare the talk and then I
talk to her again when she's booked me
back I said well he said that look you
must speak from the Hindu perspective I
said well if the Hindu perspective I
will talk about my favorite philosopher
so what I'll hear from what you will
hear from me today is about someone I
admire strongly who lived in India and
whose work I think has a great
importance in
present-day understanding of cognition
and intelligence
his name is Sankar what I'll guide you
through is to return so since it's a
since it is since it's supposed to be
hindu hindu talk so i will kind of first
give you a little bit of background out
what hindus think and then I will put
Shankara in the Hindu manifold the
hindus ideas at the following hindu as a
warp roll is not very old but indian as
a word role is more older indian means
like india was called differently before
but things coming from india it's a long
time ago i would say several thousand
years ago definitely there are the time
where indians strongly felt about
finding something called truth now truth
in this particular point of view or
mathematical point of view if you read
the scriptures and literature strongly
you'll find what was bothering them was
something that has little higher
timescale something is not transient
something will leave tomorrow and
tomorrow may be somewhat like hundred
years five hundred years thousand years
depending upon the philosopher this
particular thing which they will call
bing which say something exists all
right that will be called truth
something is being now from that bing to
really create a situation of philosophy
of this bing all right so basically you
have being and non-being and from the
bings things that are somewhat permanent
some heart in the world in some
stability they will create a philosophy
the fundamental parts of which
philosophy would be consciousness and
nature that is all beings are endowed
with two fundamental qualities
consciousness and nature
these are sanskrit words which i've
translated but basically they're kind of
clothes literal translation nature is
the property of the individual the
property of the Bing the way the Bing
operates the way the being interacts
with society the way they being interact
with the environment consciousness is
something that helps him helps her helps
it do things right so this separation
which has no metaphysical or godly
impetus in it was very basic that
everybody is undoubted endowed with a
consciousness and with the nature and
nature can be of diverse manifold but
consciousness is a part of the being in
order to activate the nature going
somewhat further the nature would have
three different elements nature nature's
manifestation is the body the physical
body that body will have three different
elements the first element intellect
intelligence and ego intellect is
something that you are endowed with
genetic intellect is something that you
have less control but somehow which
helps you organize which else you obtain
things
and accommodate things intelligence is
something that you do your cognitive
abilities your brain activities in which
you try to manipulate you try to obtain
you try to create you try to accumulate
accumulate or F purchases you try to
assimilate they're all true for
intelligence and a third thing is ego
ego is who you are your own personality
all right now ego as you can see is a
function you know here we have like a
three different three different
components of the nature and so we have
the ego of being the human body itself
and human body has intelligence as a
part of it which tries to operate which
tries to make person move make gestures
make speeches make movements eat
intellect is something which helps me to
organize thoughts so basically as you
can see mind is a part of the between
the intelligence and intellect and at
those points minds of individual points
mind becomes a part of intellect now
this particular ego can have several
attributes cosmologically cosmological
means if you transcend this particular
theory to a larger scale like the
universe has a consciousness the
universe has a nature universe has a
intellect the universe of the
intelligence and universe has Rigo if we
have an ego which carries your structure
the universe structure has its own ego
from all of that point of view ego can
have five cosmic elements this is again
old they say that leaves three four
thousand year or material
the point is to create a model of the
universe into bringing to the human
psyche and to create a metaphorical
operation in which we can understand
ourselves by the universe was these
people's strong contribution the five
elements as a note here are the sky air
Fire Water and Earth I do not know
whether somebody what kind of empirical
work went on to standardize this was
there any work at all to say the sky
could be the first element but as you
see the material henceforth you will
find people probably did meditator or
did speculate on things and coming to a
conclusion that if there's a fundamental
element in the universe that could be
the space that could be devoid that
could be the creation of space between
objects all right I think some people
who are familiar with Hinduism might
also know or might think that because of
that they somehow revered sound sound
needs the space to move so why Hindu
people are so much of fascinated with
sounds comes back from this very very
early thoughts that the sky space become
the fundamental element in the
cosmological universe of the Hindus when
I say Hindus I'm saying the people who
taught in these lines and which probably
continues to be true even at the modern
times and that's how it kind of pleases
me to present such material to from the
cognitive point of view so sky air Fire
Water and Earth in this particular order
sky will gives rise to air air gives
rise to fire fire gives out of water
what are you ready to earth in some kind
of a continuous succession
and that is how the development takes
place now once these five elements which
are orthogonal was independent which are
kind of mutually exclusive they are even
though one origin is from the other once
they are in place they do not interact
with each other all right they're
separate and once they are in place they
could give rise to or to carry the
message of of each of these elements
then human beings or the so called
beings can create evolutionary way
create this sense organs our sensory
perception our sensory perception from
this point of view is designed because
of the cosmic elements sensory
perceptions being five and the elements
being five there's one-to-one
relationship between the sensory
perception and the cosmic element now to
the sky space is here is carries found
and not to hear sound you have ears the
arm the the air carries the pressure the
molecules and not to get the filling of
the molecules you have the touch
sensation have the skin similarly far it
gives you the same the the presentation
of materiality the the view and so that
gives you the eye and then the tongue
the test and the nose the smell so these
five organs can be created once these
five organs are created then these
philosophers will go a little further
and they will say that that human beings
are composed of some more organs which
are the hands legs the procreation
excretion and the speech the mouth and
finally maybe if you want to have mind
as an exclusive organ exclusive element
you also add
mind so this is the Hindu universe which
even father today conceived developed
probably somehow empirically debated
maybe three four thousand years ago but
when a person takes bow a bow is born
dies during his life somehow people have
this belief that this is how the body is
composed of and this is how the body
will deal with the principle part of it
I must say in this whole thing that all
these so-called developments they took
place from the right-hand element which
is the nature the consciousness did not
interact with all the development the
consciousness is an entity nature is an
entity and this nature through its own
processes develops the various elements
and the Norgan and eventually beings and
beings become human beings and so on
okay if that's so then what happens at
this time they will think about that
suppose the consciousness is endowed in
all beings and they are the guiding
factors in all beings so naturally there
is a element of consciousness in all
beings okay
this particular thought which eventually
we have called soul or something which I
distorted accepts and I think generally
we have become become become addicted to
a system that yes we have a soul and
soul is the one which cognizes the soul
is the one which understands suffers
soul is the one which probably
eventually takes our life wherever it
needs to go some kind of religious
thoughts have been associated with the
soul originally however these people did
not think that way
they thought the soul would be an
element of consciousness and because
consciousness does not transform oh by
the way when I say consciousness and
nature and from the point of view of the
time scales are talking about all right
it's the nature because it evolves it
has a shorter time scales because these
things evolve form they might change but
consciousness has a much much larger
time scale most likely it doesn't change
at all all right from the original
theory now coming back here now so the
soul would be then an element of
consciousness and because the original
consciousness has a very long time scale
the individual souls consciousness will
also have a strong time scale what
follows because of that from the point
of view of the body when the body decays
body dies this time scale the soul is
longer than the body so it might look as
though the soul is immortal it might
look as though the soul doesn't die and
soul remains in the universe once
created doesn't go anywhere stays in the
universe what does it do it has it
becomes say arm what they call a passive
witness why becomes passive it's a
passive witness passive witness because
it doesn't act I must tell you also one
more thing here during this particular
discussion about the Hindu cosmology or
the time of this will our philosophical
discourses on this the question of time
strongly came in and people thought the
definition of time would be something
that differentiates
the object is there the object has moved
the position has changed the the
different realization has come in and
that will kind of make you feel that as
though some time has left so from that
point of view because the soul has a
long time scale all right so it should
not react even though my hand moves my
mouth speaks
even though I have personally moved all
right my soul is not moving with me
because it operates on a longer time
scale
all right so it basically because of
that it will stay inert so once we
define this once we make this particular
framework then we come to the
experiments that people have done lately
and I want to project them in view of
funcles work those experiments have
shown I think the following these are
accepted by the Indian philosophers and
I think lately the different experiments
in Europe and this country have come to
such kind of conclusion that is we do
operate on different brain waves we do
operate on different kind of systemic
cognition on our brain function
depending upon how we exercise our brain
depending upon how intensely the brain
is working how relaxed the brain is the
concept that these people have from the
point of view of their own thinking that
the consciousness which I said soul
which I said is a part of universal
consciousness may exist in four quantum
states one state is as we are waking
which is very strongly if you take the
brain regions you will find
that the brain is functioning pretty
fast but is functioning what the the
aborts the 20 cycles a second all right
it's kind of very strongly operating
because different kind of sensory
perceptions are coming to the brain
different kind of ideas are coming to
the brain and you are dealing with all
the different functionalities then you
come to the a dream dream which kind of
semi awake alright we're not really
fully cognizant of everything is going
on you are slept but not fully slept all
right and that situation the brain has
slowed down considerably it's probably
has gone down to about eight cycles a
second and also people know that as you
close your eyes and so on you can
possibly see these different images
visions and so on which is a part of the
whole cyclic process that brain goes
through when the brain is somewhat
slowed down not as compared to the
completely awake state then the two
other states which are this sleepy state
or sleeping state which is kind of the
original original thought of the soul
that the person is living and however
simply the body is sleeping that means
that the person's life is not really
fully gone away person's senses are not
fully gone away and the soul is only
active so in that state people say like
the we have the Delta wave which is the
one cycle a second and so on which is
operating on your brain functioning
alright however the fourth state which I
call the awakened state which these
people talk about very strongly and I
can't really give a good example of what
an awakened state might look like but
except I will kind of comment the
following I will say that when you are
strongly focused when attention is
concentrated
when you are dealing with a particular
process with utmost sincerity where as
though your whole senses are focused on
that particular object it is either to
rescue a person saving your own child
helping a friend in strong distress or
being very lonely yourself on any
particular problem where you are deeply
to yourself all right so I think such
kind of states which kind can happen
momentarily to us
all right where we don't really get
cognizance of all our senses are all
because they're so focused or even like
for students and so on you're doing your
homework for tomorrow when the exam is
there and so on and you don't really
care what's going on around so that
could be a state where you're you are
fully fully fully fully conscious of
only yourself and not receiving the
sensory input from anywhere what happens
in such situation it could be I think no
experiment have been done would be that
probably you don't have a wave at all
you will simply have a DC current you
will simply have a situation where you
will have like a full the brain is
functioning but brain not functioning
any undulating manner but various
functioning as though it is steady as
though it is operating with full
attention now such particular thought
such particular state is shankara will
deal very strongly with let me now come
to Shankara or before I come I want to
pitch two more words here that in this
theory that we have
because this consciousness can be all
around us consciousness can take two
different manifestations or what we call
manifest consciousness on manifest
consciousness and then people have you
know Hindus have called them gods Hindus
have called them you know like when
somebody has endowed with strong
consciousness where he's cognizing
everything easily quickly strongly has
strong values and so on they have been
associated with godly nature in this
particular philosophy but in general
also the consigns consciousness may be
may be all around us all right but
doesn't manifest itself as a physical
object you see you must understand this
in other consciousness to manifest a
physical object is not associate itself
with some nature right and so
consciousness may not manifest at all
but may be present all around us and
that we can call God or we can call God
something we're an embodiment of
consciousness did take place and which
kind of went through the normal natural
cycle controlled by the nature so this
brings us to our philosopher friend
Sankara Sankara we sankhara liberal on
800 AD a prolific writer and what we
know so far
that is a strong debater debater because
when you write make some thoughts which
may be somewhat different than who the
establishment thinks at the particular
time so people might try to argue with
you so he was probably spent most of his
time in debating his views with the
other people most people at that point
we're Buddhist Buddhists who would not
really who think I'll say like what the
difference is but basically the
difference would be that further our
consciousness our understanding our
cognition our Intel
is controlled by us or our intellect is
controlled by our health by assisted by
a consciousness which is larger than us
that's the principle difference and as
you see
Sankara will argue now that that that
particular the intellect operates but
interacts into intellect is endowed
always with this blessing of large
consciousness from which it draws its
resources how does he do it he defines
three terms he defines something called
nor something called knowledge something
called known sanur is the actor the one
which does one which sees one which
here's one which remembers one which
decides so that's the nor so in all
cognition process Sankar will say that
something a quantity called nor exists
so the question is can we find what the
no Ares in our body mind nature system
knowledge is easy
we know that whatever whenever we try to
know things or search for things or you
can search always for knowledge and
knowledge we acquire but I'll come in a
second but Sankar will think about
knowledge and then finally known known
is your accumulated knowledge known is
your decision process known is how much
you can really reach out to your own
consciousness and knowledge to associate
new objects into that knowledge and this
comes the catch Sankara sketch what is
the singular sketch is Oh before I do
that three definitions
what's the knower
nor you just the intellect mind you
again we have defined intellect
intelligence and ego so nor if you just
intellect that we can know you know
don't know anything we have to
discriminate we have to use our
collected knowledge to disseminate do
decipher what's up there
what's anchor will say different though
that this particular cognition is a
superposition of the consciousness on
the intellect that is the intellect is
looking for a solution intellect is
looking for assimilation intellect is
looking for adding the stuff to the
accumulated knowledge but intellect is
not sufficiently aware to find out
everything about the new object so
unless intellect is conscious intellect
will fail to operate intellect is
biological intellect part of nature into
the part of the body and that has to
associate itself with the consciousness
in order to make itself cognize the
object that it receives so this is
hunkers first hypothesis on nor the
knowledge is a perception of the
intellect we all perceive we all all our
own ideas about things so he agrees with
that that you can have your own theories
you can have your own feelings about
various objects various motions various
functions but he says you have to then
go beyond that and to see how much of
that knowledge is universal is that
knowledge strictly to yourself or
anybody else agrees with you
in order to make that particular
transition Sankar will go a very very
long step forward will say that all
knowledge if they reclassify that
knowledge they have to be true they have
to be true they must have a value they
must have a value which is not transient
remember I said the time scale so it
should not be a small time scale
operation but in knowledge if you know
it has a time scale much larger than
your perception time scale he will say
like look every time the sensory organ
is operating and you are receiving
information creating images you are
trying to think the images are stable
because of persistence because of the
new image has something to the old image
and you did not distinguish between the
new image and the old image however
whether that is truth in it is a
function of if the image lasts for
pretty pretty pretty pretty pretty long
time and that you can only do because
your intellect is only operating a short
time scale you associate that with the
long time scale consciousness such that
you can see yes there is truth in this
particular feeling the truth in this
particular message the truth in this
particular thought because of this he
will make this second assertion that is
our intellect is not capable of finding
the truth our body intellect is not
capable of finding the truth because
body intellect is conditioned by the
body experiences is conditioned by the
knowledge that received before it
conditioned by the accumulation of
material that it has received hence it
is not capable of deciphering
information which is new to it which
means the child starts up whether he
will start smiling or crying
is that a function of child's intellect
is a function of consciousness with the
child's intellect interacts with and
then cut which intellect receives the
message that look smiling is good for
you similar hypothesis similar
hypothesis that when we have we have a
decision to make our intellect is
incapable of getting into the depth of
the problem and making us peel assisted
on the problem and then the intellect
searches for and when the intellect
searches for it the consciousness which
kind of then health the intellect okay
Hey look the dissolution right now this
consciousness what the intellect can
reach it or not that's up to the
intellect but the theory is that that
consciousness exists and intellect can
reach out all right and I'll come in a
minute how do you reach out and then
known so he will say what's known is a
function of evidence is a functional
inference and function articulation
whether you can really speak it right so
no one is always that kind of easy
that's easy because because you know you
can always state it but then when you
say when you say words all right by
explaining images by comparing this man
is a man because the man has two legs
and so on two hands and stand select and
so on so that's like evidence but when
you say the man I describe this person
by having seen this person using words
that gives me a different kind of
cognition because I don't know so much
about the person I will describe the
person as I see it which is not the full
story and hence I must be consciously
intellectually active blessed with this
overall consciousness to help me to
stabilize what I know about the things
so that I can articulate
so this is the story about the knower
knowledge and known then he will say
that because of this dilemma that
intellect is only limited by the human
experience by the human thoughts or by
the human memory so the first paradox
would be we will never know the knower
in other words you know that you
intellect functions you know that we
intellect helps you understand but you
do not know how that intellect functions
the intellect has functioned by virtue
of consciousness which has assisted in
gaining the particular cognition and
because you have no access to the car
the consciousness hence you can't you it
is beyond the intellect and it's beyond
the intellect intellect doesn't perceive
it integrally feels it shankara's
metaphor is it's like light huh the
consciousness is like light it's a light
something that you don't see but you
only feel it when light falls on you so
so you know some kind of metaphor
similar metaphor where he would say that
Noor is outside the intellect and hence
you are with intellectual energy you are
not able to and because you can't see it
all cognition is always incomplete right
why is incomplete it is incomplete
because you don't know who let you know
you have some knowledge you did find a
solution you did complete your
local cognition cycle but you did not
know how that consciousness how that
local cycle did get complete and because
of that cognition remains so then will
hypothesize two very fundamental
hypothesis which comes Shankar's
philosophy the first one is if there any
knowledge that you ought to know you
must know didn't nor is the no or which
helped you cognize through your
intellect assisted you so if you have
any search for knowledge then you search
for the nor and knowledge is
consciousness so nor is knowledge and
knowledge itself is consciousness what
it means now which means that every
thought every idea every cognition is
endowed with an intellectual curiosity
but that curiosity is not complete till
a consciousness a a conscious effort has
been made to cognize and that conscious
effort is not within your discretion but
it is a pure connection it's a pure
grace it's a pure assistance by the
universal cut consciousness onto
intellect so you know so these are the
two hypothesis once he has the
hypothesis I will kind of say that that
that he'll go a step further and he will
say that look look look
you will conclude that look you have
intelligence you know i titled my talk
intelligence and god so he will say that
look your intelligence guides you in
search of knowledge search of knowing
things all right but your the way you
should guide your intelligence is to is
to is to the arm your intelligence is in
search of knowledge but intelligence
limited by your perception and delusion
delusion is the word which we'll use
very strongly that is you think you know
you think you are
you have cognize the object completely
but that's an illusion that's it you are
deluded
you're deluded because your body your
senses have failed you they have kind of
given you an impression which is the
local transient momentary very short
time scale so in order to make a larger
time scale more permanence have stronger
stable knowledge you must search more
and if you search more then you try to
get the knowledge if you get the
knowledge however you can't get the full
knowledge on unless you know the nor
who's the knower is knowledge so the
ultimate knowledge is the knower and
that I did not use the word he will use
a word called brahman so he will say
that look there's only one truth in the
universe that is this cosmic ultimate
consciousness that you call Brahman
which is pervading every object
everywhere all over the place and then
that helps you intellectually to gain
understanding of various objects what
has it with machine intelligence
is the machines will no methines know
them objectively machines don't perceive
machines tell you what the facts are so
we can train the machines to really go
become smarter and smarter and then be
consciously objective knowledge being
all parts of consciousness so all the
knowledge that we know consciously which
have been endowed through consciousness
to us if we accumulate together maybe we
can asymptotically reach this large
consciousness thank you she said I must
stop at 5:27 take questions I start 528
the questions thank you very much for me
actually that was very new I've never
did anything with Hinduism so I'm
fascinated and I'm actually especially
fascinated when I have the right to kind
of ask the first question please do
let's do it how close that is to this
whole Western idea of this whole first
of all the whole body mind split and the
whole subjectivity objectivity dilemma
yes and I would like to if that's the
point is it doesn't contradict what
happens the following like the modern
psychological theory that how does our
intelligence operate I think I used
those words before but it operates in
three Moore's assimilation accommodation
organization assimilation is a function
of the brain intellect the accommodation
of the function the mind an organization
function a memory what he's saying that
this whole three processes even though
they look biological they are not
biological they're conscious that you
are only
limited by your biology by your body
structure by your memory by your brain
to receive the knowledge as much as you
can gain as much as you can really
obtain so what you do is if you stay in
a so-called awaking state where your
mind is fully focused where your
cognition is total at that point you
will see that the knowledge that comes
to you is only the pure knowledge but
what happens though people who have
written about it and people who have
probably reached such a state they will
say that that point you don't
distinguish between objects so that's
the catch there the catch is that once
you have you don't have undulations when
the times become still you understand
when the differentiation doesn't exist
and things become cognitively
indifferent and hence you don't have any
physical perception because you have
suspend your senses so that's a dilemma
there that is one can fully reach such a
state but you must have some kind of
your natural perception still continuing
so that you can receive this so-called
understanding that you're trying to
receive otherwise you are towards the
god or you are - you know you are
reached a point where your senses are
not really important anymore the only
thing is important to you or has been
important to you only is this flat field
consciousness yes
yes would you mind repeating the
questions for thee yes the answer is yes
the answer that's exactly I thought this
import is is interesting that is the
activity if you can't say artificial you
know I call I think I was I did not use
the fridge but I will call objective
intelligence we are operating on two
modes objective intelligence something
which has longer time scale which does
not get doesn't get refuted I see you I
see you exactly the way I have seen you
before
so our perception of reaction our
interaction between the two people will
not change in the next five days next 10
days next 10 years because we understand
each other so that's our cognitive
reactionary operation between two
individuals two beings now once that
particular time scale is shortened you
go out as I don't know you I got as the
years I thought that guy all right so
then what happens is you are operating
on a lower level under subjective
intelligence where as a mutual
convenience were operating on as though
that we have something to deal with
we're business we have interest we have
togetherness which is smaller compared
to the larger permanence that knowledge
would be all about that truth be all
about and hence the weidy are like the
Machine point of view that machines will
not change once we train them on the
objective intelligence whatever we have
found all right naturally objective
intelligence again have their own
timescales
right you know Newton's laws relativity
the things do happen so
things are not permanent but we have
some semi-permanent we can build in and
hence probably we can create super smart
machines who deal with that who are not
really subjectively cognizing for
objective recognizing who cannot really
go
you know something dressed up and so on
yes this looks good alright no I know
that man I know the nature and I mean
like whatever we can fool that's exactly
Sankar will talk very strongly that we
are subjectively all the time fooling
ourselves all right so you have to go
inside strongly concentrate who you are
and then find out you have a basic
inside of you and objective intelligence
and that is independent of you yes
differently done
I think the because bleach did not know
that - just Sanskrit and so on
it probably when the Alexander came to
India at that time this apology
established the five elements and so on
but I don't think he spent enough time
or the people in interact knows enough
to really carry this out - and by the
also like by the time I started it all
by that time so I think he's material
you know I mean like he's doesn't wait
for I just you know I was going to come
back and deliver a material so and also
like space as a concept all right means
I um there's a lot hypothetical like
whether they took the five elements and
chopped one and so on because the void
interesting but I don't think that's the
case I think what the I think the
visible operations you can make is
cosmology out of the elements are total
in elements right but to think about
space as an element to sound as a
attribute to that element and human
beings have a speech at the
fundamentally different than other
objects to make that happen so those are
all metaphysical which probably Indians
were somewhat advanced than the Greeks
at that time yeah
down at all time primitive because the
ideas are means because it's
thousand-year-old is primitive or
because you think you know sign doesn't
answer this we go back to consciousness
see consciousness of the particular
verse exactly went to the brain mapping
project the consciousness if we can find
in your brain what cells are there which
makes you conscious it's not it's not a
function of how you hear how you see or
how you sense is a function of what
makes you conscious our instruments at
the present time our thoughts the
present time have failed to even
understand how we synthesize how the
mind function even you from sensory
perception what you're receiving is only
some kind of sketches receiving only
small signals in Morrisville in the
beginning that we have this very very
sketchy signals are coming from
different directions to you you are
processing them to create an image that
processing how it is done which part of
the brain does that we don't know that's
the reason why we are going to make this
5 micron brain map hopefully we can
navigate and see where it is happening
not that I can guarantee we can see it
but that's the question the question is
we have all these neurons we know how
these neurons are activating themselves
we know how they reflect how they're
reacting to different sensory operations
but we don't
know how they're synthesizing if they're
synthesizing what times color
synthesizing and then the question is if
they're synthesizing what happens to the
perception of it the knowledge of it and
cut what the consciousness you are a
good question
consciousness could be some kind of a
genetic cell that's what I think it
could be very minored sell which proper
eights in all of us in different degree
and probably in some process we get
activated too it could be but you can't
deny the fact that you're conscious of
you that you are not conscious all the
time you can't deny the fact that some
time you're conscious some time not
conscious and your brain doesn't say
that with the same brain the same memory
the same mind the same intellect same
body same blood goes unconscious that's
the question it happens in children more
yes no please please go to answer a
second question yes yes second question
was to the structure to the structure of
the lecture series I I don't try to
reconcile religion and science I try to
present a variety of different
scientists and their ways to deal with
these two so today professor misra tries
to reconcile them we had other people
who try to keep them apart
we have other people who try to keep
them kind of in a balance but still I
try to present a variety of people with
different ways so it's not an overall
objective goal to bring the two together
I don't know it says probably your first
lecture otherwise you
I would like to hear two people try to
invite those people but people if you
think that science is bogus are not
scientists and therefore they wouldn't
they I cannot present them here
scientists doing that stuff and people
who hate religion I invited several
people and they all deny to come so in
that sense it's no if you ask me what my
personal opinion religion is bogus okay
I didn't say the religion at all you
know usually what religion at all that
no religion is the question ignorance
ignorance to the point that you use a
perception and perception with short
timescale I don't know what's your you
are physicist chemist computer scientist
yeah
it's a time scale we're talking about
cosmology we're talking about how a
universe begins how do they never
sustain itself do the laws that we think
are true here are true elsewhere are the
true in you and me if not why not what
we are talking consciously from our
small experiment which you can do
yourself that you and your friend sing
the same object may not have the same
perception that's what the cognitive
weakness comes in if it the same if you
you can make experiments the color you
can X Mexican the Stars you can make
experiments on the you know why the why
why we thought astrology was the
important parameter for a long time
where people still think the sky looks
2d sky looks like it's Perico that's a
cognitive weakness the sky which expands
so much behind looking to you as a spear
stars hanging in this particular spear
he's our cognitive weakness ignorant
and we stayed with it for a long time we
still probably you know whatever you
know now is still weak so that is what
you didn't quell that is their truth
means how long in knowledge what
timescale the knowledge may have and
whether we can always receive full
cognitive conscious feedback from our
observation from our senses what he's
saying again I don't know whether it is
right or wrong who talks hunker I think
it's a pleasure to talk some current
someone because I admire him but what he
says is that probably you never access
to full truth then he of course becomes
godly and so on which you can question I
didn't saw his I made it like a little
picture for him we did not come out well
but you know it kind of inkjet thinking
kind of you know you will kind of Sarkar
they say wow he saw there like a
religious persons picture here and so on
but I will show you anyway it's kind of
a typical you know the way it's some
kind of artist projection of the man
alright but the point is why this man
thinks about this weather just scientist
religious scholar philosopher or have a
very high IQ I don't know but what kind
of makes me wonder that he did think
about this particular knowledge and
ignorance in the scientific way that
Piazza talks about in 1923 the same
things not with that particularly tale
but with experimental way I don't think
he did an experiment it's pure intuition
okay what else yes
[Music]
machine is conditioned to be
knowledgeable to the point that to
inject knowledge to it like all we are
yeah yeah what it's not hinder lien from
Sankar I think they suppose you ask a
Hindu religious persons on he will say
he knows it he knows it go to you know
do prayer do something something you
know what this is truth is but what he
kind of analyzes is that what you say
the truth has presented to you without
having a full dose of consciousness is
only perception you take it with bit a
pinch of salt
you take it with lot of apprehension and
then you really see the consciousness I
think I don't know I think the 2d they
do like in this la jolla I think in for
that gentleman la jolla that doing the
yoga as a as a technique to determine
consciousness they're trying to do
experiments to see whether we can really
see like when the person is kind of
concentrating strongly whether we can
measure the brain function all right so
that results will come out they not come
out to it I think last week there some
kind of a thought Brian or some kind of
a epileptic you know epilepsy like those
kind of results came out in neuroscience
come in a conference last week but some
more things will come in next they said
this is the year the brain right so
decayed of the brain so any other
question yes okay
I don't think the I don't think the
cognition like what whether you feel but
what happens when you go to the
objective intelligence like human beings
no I think again no see this has been
done by children suppose our first
concern
surface tension you have a bunch of kids
ten kids all right
you quiz them how much they know what
didn't know all right then you can find
out that how far the where the loopholes
are but the adults is difficult to do
because adults have so much different
knowledge and an experiment to say that
look where the ignorance level is and
how high the ignorance level is what we
do is we do the testing we do like the
exams and so on and people flunk people
move things happen like that but there
is no cognitive test that yes I know my
friend I know my father I think mother
and son probably different because
mothers know the sons but sons do not
know the for example I tell you one my
particular experience my part
somebody I look somewhat different in my
family know why so yeah we had I like a
person who are working for in a home and
see kind of made me feel that I my mom a
little strict seems very strong
disciplinarian
so see will kind of always yell that if
I don't come home at a particular time
or something so this woman for whatever
reason she will tell me that look you
are not her son you know I mean I was
like 11 12 year old and something I said
wow how do I deal with this you know how
to deal with this what is this
so I talked I heard like you know my
father is a liberal person so we had
like a I called the conference my father
the mom was there and this thing I sat
down I said like I only important to ask
and so on and then they said they're
sitting here I'm sitting here so I told
them it was 1959 I asked them I asked my
dad that how do I know I'm your son how
do you know you're your father's son you
can do a DNA test now Sumter didn't know
that the my point is these are cognitive
issues issues that you through your
perception through your senses you're
receiving information from the other
object to create an association that
Association how scientific it is how
truthful it is how objectivity is up to
you what this says it can't become
objective if you are totally conscious
unfortunately we are not all the time
fully conscious is that a way to be
conscious we'd not know the religion
takes over there okay very good
thank you again thank you so much
[Applause]